بعيدا عن ضجيج المدينه والمال والسلطه
وعلى واحد من اجمل شواطئ سيدني تعزل سيده
سبعينيه نفسها مع الطبيعه لكنها تتقدم بين
الفينه والاخرى مع اعمال الخير التي تقوم
بها ازاء المجتمع هناك اما ما هو معروف
عنها فانها مربيه وكاتبه وهي كذلك
التي تملك ثروه تقدر بنحو ثمانيه مليارات
ومئه مليون دولار فما سر هذه الثروه ولدت
عام 1950 في ولايه هاواي الامريكيه وتعلمت
هناك في مدرسه للبنات اسستها والدتها
باربرا كوكس التي كانت اغنى سيده في هاواي
وابنه جيمس انكوكس الذي حكم الولايه لثلاث
مرات واسست تكتل كوكس انتربرايس في عام
1898 عندما قام بشراء الصحيفه
ثم طورها لتصبح شركه اتصالات وسيارات
ووسائل اعلام بعد ان انهى الدراستها تدربت
بلير لتصبح معلمه وعملت بالمدرسه التي
اسستها والدتها ثم انتقلت الى استراليا
حيث عاشت مع زوجها السابق صايمون ويليام
بيري اوكين في ضواحي بلده سكون في دون ان
تترك اهتمامها بالتعليم حيث انضمت لعضويه
مجلس مدرسه سكون جرامر في البلده وتولت
اداره مركز رعايه المسنين هناك قبل ان
تبدا بالكتابه للاطفال وتنشر في عام
1989 كتابا تعليميا بعنوان
في عام 2007 بعد وفاه والدتها ورثت بلير
ربع ملكيه شركه كوكس انتر برايس التي تراس
شقيقها جيمس كندي مجلس ادارتها دون ان
تفكر بان يكون لها اي دور في الشركه مع
ذلك كان لنجاح الشركه التي تقدم خدمات لما
يقرب من سته ملايين منزل وشركه الاثر
عليها ففي مارس عام 2009 قدر الثروتها
بنحو سبعه مليارات دولار كما اعتبرت اغنى
امراه في استراليا عام 2016
اليوم وبفضل شركه كوكس انتربريز التي تعد
ثالثه اكبر مشغل للكابلات في الولايات
المتحده نمت ثروه بلاير لتقدر بنحو ثمانيه
مليارات ومئه مليون دولار امريكي وفقا
لقائمه المليارديرات من فورس وهي الثروه
التي ساعدتها لتواصل اعمالها الخيريه
والتربويه بعيدا عن الاضواء بالطريقه
ذاتها التي اختارت فيها ان تسكن في واحد
من سته منازل فقط يعيش اصحابها على شاطئ
بيلجولا في سيدني
[موسيقى]